virgin hotels las vegas opens to guests
for the first time in about an hour and
a half
las vegas weekly is showcasing all the
changes and new offerings at the resort
in this week's magazine
we have editor at large brock ratke
joining us and brock this is a complete
changeover which areas will we
see the biggest difference yeah i mean
really the whole resort looks a lot
different from what
i remember used to frequent the hard
rock hotel
the colors and design back then
everything was a little bit
darker a little bit more rock and roll
of course and now
everything is in these desert sunset
colors
if you walk into the main casino the
grand entrance
you're gonna immediately notice a very
striking difference
and what are some of those brand new
features we've heard a lot about the
casino rock
yeah well as with any kind of renovation
of a casino property they're bringing in
quite a few
new operators one that i'm really
excited about is a
very popular thai restaurant from los
angeles called night and market
also the you know the former pink taco
mexican restaurant that was really
popular with locals as well as tourists
has turned into something new called
casa calavera
similarly a mexican restaurant but
upgraded and completely different
there's a lot of new restaurants that's
like the biggest change is the
restaurants and just the overall design
but really i think what the hot spot at
virgin is going to be
what they call the backyard area where
the day club and the resort pool
and this new event lawn is located at
look at that that's gorgeous
wow that's a beautiful pool
let's talk some music now brock i love
going to concerts there at the joint
what does the
new concert hall look like now
the good news is that the joint isn't
going anywhere uh
it's still going to be a 4500 capacity
huge concert hall like you're saying
they're still going to have
big touring shows from from huge artists
and residencies and comedy and that same
eclectic programming
aeg las vegas is going to continue to
program the room
but it is going to change it's going to
have a different name
eventually and it's been completely
renovated all the
finishes redone and they've added some
new vip spaces so i think it's going to
be a new experience but still
familiar for people who used to go there
and i mean this happened quickly we were
talking just a year ago the hard rock
was coming down
they timed it perfectly because things
are opening back up now i mean they
couldn't timed it any better
what do you think brock yeah i mean
everything's
things are starting to open up again
gradually uh we've already seen a brand
new casino opening downtown in the last
few months with circa in october
that was a really big deal and we've got
another big one coming this summer with
resorts world on the strip
virgin is different because it is one of
these renovating
property type of jobs instead of
something
built from the ground up it's very
difficult to create something that
really
feels new but it looks like they've done
a really good job of doing just that
it certainly does well we look forward
to seeing the article thank you so much
for your time brock
and we'll check back with you in a week
to two